kpop star Sully formerly of the band FX  has died at the age of 25 the singer and  actress was found dead in her home  outside of Seoul by her manager on  Monday afternoon according to multiple  reports  Sully's manager spoke to her Sunday  evening and went to check on her when he  was unable to reach her on Monday police  say they found a note at the scene but  have yet to analyze its contents and  investigations are still ongoing  [Music]  Sully whose real name is Choi Jin REE  was a child actor before making her  singing debut at the girl group in 2009  [Music]  she left the group in 2015 to  concentrate on acting before returning  to the music scene as a solo artist  releasing her single Goblin in June  [Music]  the melody menchaca  [Music]